jeff bezos response to viral clip of
of uh lauren sanchez and leo
jokes leo come over here amazon
co-founder 57 years old monday threw
down the playful threat while poking fun
at a video that went viral over the
weekend the clip document in a moment
that he and the partner lauren sanchez
shared with dicaprio at lacma art and
film gala in l.a saturday in the brief
the emmy award-winning journalist 51 can
be seen flashing a big smile at the 46
year old actor a long-time co-chair of
the annual event while bezos stands by
her side leo is mr steele your girl bar
still sports chokingly said about this
uh and then he says let's come over here
i want to show you something leo and
then he put that with a danger fatal
drop sign so if you want to go back to
uh the danger of fatal drop sign look at
that
uh cliff
okay which is funny good for you for
showing sense of humor and by the way
look at those traps
okay guys in shape
guys
the guy's been working out mr yogurt who
is that what song is that mr still your
girl
yeah
all right
thoughts do you have any thoughts yeah
here we go
could leo steal jeff bezos girl
absolutely i'm sure he could bro
freaking leonardo dicaprio do you think
leo she's too old for him there you go
you think leo who is what age
46 has any interest whatsoever in lauren
sanchez who's 51 years old or 50
yeah 51 no
zero interest
if there's a number three
she's attractive she's too old for him
if there's a number three in front of a
woman's age leo hang got no interest
ricky gervais said it best what do you
say he said it best when he said
listen
you know the movie uh uh the the
the mob movie that they created
he saw the irishman i watched it good
movie a little too long but i watched it
as a matter of fact the movie's so long
that leonardo dicaprio won with his day
to watch the movie by the time the movie
ended
exactly the girl he's dating right now
camila maroney
is 24 years old makes sense the last
girl he dated yeah it was actually a
girl from miami who i know hung out
there a million times nina agdal she's
been on the cover of sports illustrated
she just turned 29.
so he saw the writing on the wall he's
like listen a little too old for me you
know leo i think abides by the
um
half your age plus seven so he's 46 half
your age 23 plus seven that's 30. that's
too old for him he's like half your age
minus seven is basically where he's at i
said that's illegal right there i think
he just follows the half your age theory
is what he does he follows half the age
theory yeah you know what you're
interested
if you go back to the video
i see one person wearing a mask in la
and that's the waiter in the background
there
by the way do you see james goldstein in
the back he's they got the old guy with
the hat with the long hair yeah he's at
every single nba game in the yeah yeah
that guy's a maid man over there in the
nba
is there a is there a more eligible
bachelor on the planet than leonardo
dicaprio
is there adam sosnick so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]